[Musique]
madame chardron 35 ans habite seul dans
un grand ensemble de la banlieue
parisienne à epinay tout en élevant ses
deux enfants
pour elle la solitude n'est pas un choix
mais une fatalité de chadron pouvez vous
me dire la suite de quelle circonstance
vivait seul et bien c'est involontaire à
la suite du décès de mon mari il ya sept
ans et comment s'est passé votre votre
vie de couple j'ai vécu combien de temps
j'étais marié cinq ans et je suis seul
maintenant vous avez des enfants
j'ai deux enfants de 6 9 ans et demi et
design et comment s'est déroulée votre
vie de couple
j'ai eu une vie de couple assez
extraordinaire j'ai été très très
heureuse dix ans c'était même trop beau
pour que ça dure presque que te dire je
ne sais pas il y avait un dialogue
extraordinaire il y avait vraiment
c'était un couple et un couple qui
pouvait durer toute la vie très
finalement merveilleux lorsque vous
faites exactement comme métier
eh bien je suis infirmière et
je fais du libéral se dire je fais des
soins à domicile et je reçois des
clients aussi
et je fais des pincements aussi dans une
clinique et vous travaillez uniquement
par nécessité ou un peu pour vous
occuper quand même ah non par nécessité
sur est ce que c'est un métier qui vous
plaît on soit il vous apporte quelque
chose
ah oui c'est si j'ai choisi ce métier
j'ai choisi ce métier quand j'étais
avant de me marier avant de savoir que
je me marierai un jour et j'ai choisi
justement parce que j'avais envie de
faire ce métier me plaisait et puis il
me permettait d'être en contact avec les
gens et c'est ce contact avec les gens
que j'apprécie beaucoup d'autres
domaines que vous apporte le contact ils
m'apportent surtout le croit
l'impression de ne servir à quelque
chose que d'exister de faire exister un
peu mieux les autres je crois quand vous
regardez ce taux n'est que vous avez
passé seul que pensez vous eh bien je
crois que c'est un petit peu dommage de
les avoir vécu seul
j'estime que c'est quand même un bilan
positif pour votre ville mais malgré
cela c'est un bilan positif malgré tout
parce que je crois que maintenant bas on
vit pas trop mal comment avez vous fait
pour vivre pas trop mal c'est à dire
j'ai essayé d'abord 2
d'avoir des contacts avec d'autres
personnes j'ai fait des beaucoup de
cession de connaissance de soi qui m'a
quand même aidé me trouvais moi-même et
à me sentir plus solide à exister moi
même par moi-même et j'avoue que ça m'a
beaucoup aidé et j'ai surtout j'ai voulu
que les enfants aient une vie normale le
plus normale possible qu'il soit heureux
comme si leur père était là est ce que
par rapport aux autres enfants vos
enfants se sentent un peu marginaux un
peu différent des autres
pas tellement un petit peu de temps en
temps par pose d'une réflexion mais ils
sont non ils sont pas mal il s'en
passait bien mais pas celui-là
est-ce que vos enfants souhaiteraient
que vous vous mariez ça dépend des
moments
enfin je crois que si moi je voulais me
marier je pense qu'il serait tout à fait
d'accord du moment que je leur dis que
c'est parce que ça leur donnera je peux
pas un autre père parce que ce n'est pas
si le dire est papa ils m'ont déjà dit
un petit peu je ne sais pas si je dirais
papa mais de toute façon les moyens
d'avoir un homme avec qui dialoguer et
je pense que si je me remarier
ce dialogue serait possible et je crois
qu'il accepterait est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de vous re marier un jour
par exemple ça dépend ça dépend pas que
de moi pour se marier faut être deux et
je ne serai pas opposé au contraire bien
que maintenant après 7,1 je crois que ça
commence à être un peu tard mais
j'aurais préféré nous a mis ce sont des
il ya des femmes seules ou découplement
[Musique]
ya quelques femmes seules mais c'est
plus souvent des couples il est pour une
femme seule c'est facile d'avoir des
rapports avec un un couple ah ça c'est
pas que c'est pas facile mais il faut
faire attention c'est à dire
si on s'entend bien avec le mari il
risque d'y avoir une certaine gêne qui
secret pour la femme et si on s'entend
bien pour là avec la femme le mari aussi
se sent lésé alors quand on est tout
seul ça pose un petit peu un problème il
faut être très attentif éviter les
problèmes
est-ce que solitude vous pèse elle n'est
jamais facile à vivre et je trouve que
c'est dommage d'être seul quand on a un
tas de choses à partager dans quelles
circonstances plus précisément elle vous
vous posiez des moments où elles vous
plaisent davantage que d'autres
oui c'est au moment des difficultés
je crois que au moment où il ya des
difficultés avec les enfants surtout
s'il ya une prise de décision à prendre
au sujet des enfants pas mon sujet nous
c'est le sujet des enfants
là c'est très difficile parce qu'on ne
sait pas si on fait bien on hésite on
est on est pas très sûrs d'eux soir
ce qui vous arrive d'avoir le cafard un
peu quelquefois ah oui quand même
quand même c'est énorme
donc c'est dans quelle circonstance par
exemple peut-être quand les enfants sont
occupés
disons quand on a tout fait pour les
enfants et on voudrait parfois aussi
avoir un petit peu quelque chose pour
soi à mes enfants ne peuvent pas penser
à ça vous souffrez un peu également une
absence de vie affective un peu d'une
certaine façon surtout de l'absence de
des changes très profond oui l'absence
de je crois que autrement on peut
arriver à trouver une certaine
seigneurie sérénité c'est à dire il faut
avoir une vie active il faut s'occuper
il faut essayer de deux compensée par
l'activité
ce que l'on n'a pas dans sa vie propre
mais l'activité ou alors même un peu de
sport c'est ça fait du bien
est ce que cette solitude d'une certaine
façon a aussi des aspects positifs
positif si on veut je crois que quand on
se retrouve seul après une vie de couple
on est obligé de
[Musique]
d'assurer tout à la fois et je pense
quand même que quand on fait sa vie de
couple on abdique certaines de ses
possibilités et le fait de m'être
retrouvé seul j'ai fait un tas de choses
que je n'ai pas fait avant et je crois
qu'il faut se dire qu'on en est capable
aussi peut-être qu'on applique un peu
trop parfois dans la vie de couple
m'enfin c'est pas simple cette solitude
ne vous a pas renfermé un peu sur vous
même
non je ne crois pas j'ai toujours aimé
les échanges avec les autres j'ai
toujours eu besoin des autres et les
autres justement 113 c'est très
important pour moi être en relation et
même que les faudrait que les autres o
de demander quelque chose aux personnes
seules parce que sinon on a l'impression
de ne pas exister
c'est absolument indispensable qu'on
nous demande aussi des services qu'on
nous demande aussi parfois de garder un
enfant c'est possible on a de cantona 2
on peut en garder 3 ou 4 c'est à peu
près pareil mais on n'ose plus rien
demandé on croire oui hélas il a fait ça
à faire mais non il faut nous prendre je
pense que quand on est seule en fait
comme tout le monde
et maintenant quelle perspective
d'avenir voyez vous à votre vie je ne
sais pas trop pour le moment et bien il
faut que les enfants aillent au moins
qu'il fasse les oilers étaient un peu
d'études qui êtes peut-être un métier
puis ensuite on verra à ce moment-là
peut-être que je changerais totalement
de vie quant à eux auront continueront
plus besoin de moi envisagez-vous le
perspective de continuer même finir
votre vie sol c'est à dire si je ne
trouve pas quelqu'un avec qui m'est
possible de vivre et de refaire quelque
chose de valable
effectivement je préfère être seul parce
que je crois que si on n'a pas à côté de
soi quelqu'un avec qui on peut faire un
projet dans le temps qui dit rien je ne
sais pas et avoir un espoir de faire
durer un amour vrai c'est pas la peine
je préfère rester seul
[Musique]